te quiero platicar en este vídeo acerca
de una forma de ahorro para el retiro
que se llama rock rock y rock
y el nombre viene de el de william rock
william william ross quien fue un
senador por el estado de delaware de la
web y en 1997 apoyó que se pasará esta
ley en el senado para aprobar esta forma
de ahorrar por eso le pusieron el nombre
de rock en su honor ahora te hace estar
preguntando por qué tener una nueva
forma de ahorro si ya tenemos la
tradicional entonces vamos a comparar
ambas formas vamos a poner aquí
tradicional en una cuenta tradicional
una cuenta irá tradicional y esa la
vamos a comparar con la root una cuenta
arroz para ver pues cuáles son sus
principales diferencias y qué beneficios
podría tener abrir una cuenta de ahorros
bueno lo primerito y la principal
distinción entre estas dos es que sucede
con los impuestos déjame ponerle por acá
impuestos impuestos
y en tradicional lo que metíamos de
monto a la cuenta pues sus impuestos se
diferían verdad los impuestos estaban
diferidos diferidos por ejemplo si
metemos cinco mil dólares no teníamos
que pagar impuestos por esos cinco mil
pero en el caso de una cuenta arroz aquí
no pasa eso aquí son no diferidos
diferidos si hay que pagar impuestos por
lo que metamos en esta cuenta entonces
ahorita pues parece ser que roces está
en desventaja verdad no está padre tener
que pagar impuestos si acá no teníamos
que hacerlo vamos a las ganancias las
ganancias que tenemos y mientras
ahorramos ganancias como ya platicamos
antes en tradicional en un irá
tradicional no hay que pagar impuestos
por las ganancias que tenemos verdad al
menos mientras el dinero está en la
cuenta pues en root tampoco deja lo
escribo entonces las ganancias no pagan
no pagan impuestos
impuestos mientras están en la cuenta
mientras están
en la cuenta ok entonces esto sigue
siendo una ventaja vale entonces es una
ventaja de ahorrar en una cuenta irá en
ningún caso hay que pagar impuestos no
hay que pagar impuestos por ingresos de
capital bueno eso está padre bueno eso
está padre de las dos pero debes decir
bueno rod sigue estando en desventaja
porque aquí hay que pagar impuestos
inicialmente y en tradicional no
entonces lo realmente interesante de
root es lo que sucede una vez que
retiramos hay muchas circunstancias y
condiciones para decir que un retiro
está calificado ahorita no me voy a
meter en detalles pero el chiste es
darte nada más la idea general de por
qué rock es interesante y para eso vamos
a pensar qué sucede cuando ya tenemos
más de 59 años y medio de edad vale
entonces qué pasa a los 59 años y medio
son 59 años y medio más cinco años de un
periodo requerido ahorita no me voy a
meter mucho en eso pero ve acá en
tradicional lo que sucede es que tenemos
que ahora
al recibir el dinero pagar impuestos por
todo pagar impuestos
sin impuestos
como ya platicamos usualmente aquí
tenemos que pagar impuestos y esos son
menores a lo que teníamos que pagar
antes porque estamos en un rango menor
de impuestos verdad pero ojo aquí
tenemos que pagar impuestos por todo
incluyendo las ganancias incluyendo
ganancias ganancias y qué sucede aquí
cuando tenemos una cuenta arroz pues
aquí ya no hay que pagar nada de
impuestos no de impuestos
vale entonces en este caso tenemos el
beneficio de tener un rango menor de
impuestos y acá tenemos el beneficio de
que no pagamos nada de impuestos por las
ganancias que que generamos mientras el
dinero estaba en la cuenta entonces ya
se empieza a ver un poco más interesante
verdad después vamos a jugar con los
números para ver qué pasa vamos a otra
cosa interesante qué sucede con una
cuenta root bueno con una cuenta root
pues vamos a ver qué pasa cuando tenemos
que hacer retiros prematuros retiros
prematuros prematuros sale entonces un
retiro prematuro es un retiro antes de
cumplir los 59 años y medio como te
contaba en el vídeo pasado aquí en la
forma tradicional se tiene que pagar una
penalización no te había dicho de cuánto
pero se tiene que pagar una penalización
de 10 por ciento 10% de penalización
penalización
por lo que retiramos más los impuestos
correspondientes más impuestos ahora lo
que pasa de este lado es que aquí no hay
que pagar impuestos ni penalización
siempre y cuando saquemos menos saquemos
menos que nuestro monto principal vale
entonces lo voy a poner aquí le voy a
poner no impuestos lo va a poner sin
impuestos vale ni penalización
penalización
por por el monto principal el monto
principal
bueno e incluso aunque no aunque
tengamos que sacar más del mundo
principal y nuestro retiro no se ha
calificado nada más tenemos que pagar
una penalización de 10% e impuestos e
impuestos por las ganancias por las
ganancias vale ganancias ahorita no voy
a entrar mucho en detalles vamos a ver
un ejemplo aquí abajito pero no voy a
entrar en detalles por dos casos por dos
cosas o sea primero quiero que el vídeo
quede más o menos claro entonces no
quiero confundirte demasiado pero número
dos tampoco voy a entrar en detalles
porque hay muchas reglas y entonces las
reglas van cambiando año con año y el
gobierno pues pone un nuevo alguna nueva
condición de monto o de ingresos o lo
que sea pero bueno vamos a ver un
ejemplo para que no nos quedemos citando
al aire entonces vamos a ver un ejemplo
de un ahorro tradicional tradicional
contra un ahorro rostro vale un ahorro
root muy bien déjame ponerle la ira
tradicional y la tradicional y rocía
para que para que sepamos que son
casuales que estamos ahorrando bueno
supongamos que ganó más de cinco mil
dólares y que voy a invertir pues cinco
mil dólares porque es lo máximo que
puede invertir es el monto máximo en
algunas de estas cuentas entonces vamos
a ver qué pasa con cada una de ellas
pero antes otra cosa algo que pasa con
el rociera es que también tiene una
restricción con respecto a cuánto ganas
vaciadas mucho dinero puede ser que no
que no sea candidato a tener un rol y ya
va ahora hay algunas otras reglas y
cosas que te permiten pues aprovechar un
vacío legal porque puedes empezar con
unidad tradicional y transferir te a un
road irá pero tampoco me quiero meter en
esos detalles sería complicado
sólo quiero transmitirte esta idea de
que el rociera tiene más condiciones
para abrirlo pero que a lo mejor si eres
un poco truculento puedes darle la
vuelta bueno
pensemos entonces que pues tomamos
nuestro principal bueno tomamos una
tomamos 5000 dólares
tomamos cinco mil dólares y los vamos a
meter en estas cuentas van entonces
vamos a ver qué pasa
al principio aquí no hay que pagar nada
de impuestos le voy a poner que de
impuestos
es cero y cero dólares pero de este lado
si tenemos que pagar impuestos no se
pensemos que estamos en el rango de 32%
de 32% de en el de impuestos de
impuestos vale y entonces vamos a ver
cuánto tendríamos que pagar por estos
cinco mil voy a sacar la calculadora
entonces 32 bueno no voy a ponerle voy a
ponerle cinco mil cinco mil por punto 32
va entonces 1600 tenemos que pagar mil
seiscientos mil seiscientos
de impuestos cuánto nos quedaría nuestro
monto principal pues de este lado de
este lado el monto principal no le
estamos quitando nada entonces nos
quedaría los cinco mil dólares que
pusimos dólares y de este lado de este
lado a los cinco mil dólares tenemos que
restarle 1600 nos quedan tres mil
cuatrocientos 3.400 de monto principal
ok ese es el monto principal empieza a
transcurrir el tiempo pasan los años
invertimos en acciones y no se digamos
que después de cinco años de cinco años
años nuestro monto se duplica vale estoy
siendo muy optimista pero pues es para
que los números queden queden bien
entonces después de cinco años estos
cinco mil ahora se transforman en diez
mil dólares
diez mil dólares y estos tres mil
cuatrocientos se transforman en seis mil
ochocientos en seis mil ochocientos
dólares
muy bien ahora podríamos seguir dejando
el dinero ahí por más tiempo pero
pensemos que todavía no tenemos
cincuenta y nueve y medio pero surge un
imprevisto tenemos que realizar un
préstamo no sea nuestro cuñado porque
necesita pagar una emergencia médica y
entonces tenemos que retirar déjame
ponerle acá que tenemos que retirar
retirar y vamos a hacer dos casos
pensemos primero que nuestro cuñado
necesita si justo tres mil 400 3 mil 400
dólares va entonces al retirar esos tres
mil cuatrocientos dólares que sucedería
con respecto a las penalizaciones en
cada caso pues acá
acá pues de esos 10.000 que ahora
tenemos tenemos que sacar 3.400 3.400
pero nos van a cobrar dinero por esos
3.400 nos van a cobrar los impuestos
correspondientes y además nos van a
cobrar 340 de penalización vamos a ver
cuánto es aquí voy a poner los 340 240
dólares de penalización pensemos que
seguimos en el rango de 32 entonces
tendríamos que pagar tres mil tres mil
cuatrocientos por punto 32 de impuestos
son mil 88 le voy a poner aquí que son
mil 88 y entonces haciendo la resta al
intentar sacar 3.400 nos van a cobrar
ciertas penalizaciones y nos quedaría
3.400 menos mil 88 menos 340 y eso es
nos quedan 1972
ok entonces esto sería en el caso del
día tradicional vámonos para acá al rojo
irá pues en este caso lo que
obtendríamos serían los 3.400 los 3.400
dólares que pedimos y aquí no hay que
pagar nada aquí no hay que pagar nada ni
de impuestos ni de penalización de
impuestos ni de penalización oa poner
así penalización porque estamos sacando
estamos sacando nuestro monto principal
entonces cualquier cantidad que queramos
sacar hasta nuestro monto principal no
nos cuesta nada y nos dan todo el dinero
entonces eso está padre verdad eso está
muy bueno del tira en otro tipo de giras
pero donde el rock irá en otro tipo de
iras si hay que pagar una penalización
por por lo que saquemos por todo lo que
saquemos pero acá no acá pues esto nos
da un colchoncito verdad nuestro monto
principal nos da un colchón eso es algo
muy positivo del rock era que es
flexible para emergencias económicas
vamos a otro ejemplo qué sucede si en
vez de querer retirar 3.400 queremos
4000 voy a poner así retirar
retirar cuatro mil cuatro mil dólares
bueno ahorita ya no voy a hacer las
cuentas así concretamente nada más voy a
escribir lo que tengo que pagar en este
caso tendríamos que pagar tendríamos que
pagar pues los impuestos por esos cuatro
mil o sea cuatro mil por por 32 por
ciento 32 por ciento y además tenemos
que pagar la penalización del 10 por
ciento que es de 400 dólares ok entonces
esto sería en el caso del tradicional en
el caso del rock en el caso de el rock
irá pues tendríamos bueno por un lado
nos darían nuestros 3.400 que es el
monto principal sin ningún problema por
esto no tenemos que pagar nada de
penalización pero de los 600 adicionales
los 600 que son parte de la ganancia lo
que hemos estado ganando con el dinero
en la cuenta de ahorros por eso si
tendríamos que pagar el 32 por ciento
el 32% y el 10% de penalización entonces
60 dólares más de penalización vale que
hacer las cuentas puedes ver que de
todas formas en esta emergencia si ve y
sigue conviniendo mucho más tener un rol
tradicional entonces una vez más el root
nos da flexibilidad ante la
incertidumbre bueno pensemos que pues
que bueno estás nada más fueron
situaciones hipotéticas pero en realidad
todo salió muy bien entonces no tuvimos
que retirar ni nada de hecho pasó el
tiempo y siguió pasando él siguió
pasando el tiempo y entonces en vez de
haber tenido que retirar logramos
duplicar logramos duplicar
este nuestras nuestras cuentas de ahorro
vale entonces seguimos invirtiendo que
duplicamos los ahorros y ya llegamos al
momento del retiro a los 59 años y medio
y acá tenemos 20 mil
déjame ponerle un poco más bonito 2020
mil dólares y de este lado tendríamos el
doble el doble de 6.806 13.600 ok
entonces qué pasa ahora que ya tenemos
ya tenemos más más de 59 años y medio
vamos a ver qué ocurre en este momento
pues bueno pues ya digamos no se
pensemos que que ya llegamos a esta edad
ya no estamos ganando tanto dinero y
ahora en vez de estar en un rango de
impuestos de 30 de 32% ya nada más
tenemos que pagar 30 por ciento de
impuestos para 30 por ciento de
impuestos
bueno en este caso en el caso de lira
tradicional ahora sí tenemos que pagar
impuestos por esos 20 mil entonces hay
que pagar el 30 por ciento de esos 20
mil 30 por ciento de 20.000 es es 6000
6000 entonces en total nos quedarían 14
mil 14.000 y este ya es dinero que ya
tenemos podemos gastar para el gasto
corriente o para un coche o para lo que
queramos y de este lado la ventaja del
ros tira en este momento es que ya no
hay que pagar nada de impuestos no
impuestos
e impuestos y por lo tanto nos quedan
todos esos 13.600 13.600 muy bien
entonces ahora sí vamos a pensar tantito
que sucedió mira el rociera fue mucho
más amable con nosotros cuando
necesitamos retirar en caso de una
emergencia eso es algo que pasa con el
rock es mucho más flexible además al
final no tuvimos que pagar nada de
impuestos por por las ganancias que
estuvimos ganando en el transcurso en el
transcurso de nuestro ahorro va en el
caso del tradicional aquí si había que
pagar una penalización más fuerte y
sobre todo pues osea era era bastante
diferente en el caso en el que no nos
pasábamos del monto inicial verdad acá
también convenía más el otro pero aquí
arriba se notaba mucho más y bueno aquí
al final tuvimos que pagar impuestos y
además pagamos impuestos por lo que
estuvimos ahorrando por lo que estuvimos
ganando ganando con nuestras inversiones
entonces ve los números en realidad
quedaron muy cerca en el rosgan
un poquito menos hasta el final pero es
mucho más flexible vale entonces quería
contarte esto quería platicarte estas
cosas en este vídeo para que vieras las
ventajas y desventajas de cada una de
estas formas de ahorrar para el retiro
ya nada más déjame contarte una última
cosa una última cosa que a lo mejor es
una cosa menor dependiendo de tu
filosofía de vida verdad pero es bueno
que lo sepas acá en la forma tradicional
al llegar a los 70 años y medio de edad
de edad de edad aquí tienes que
retirarse retirar todos forzosamente
entonces hay reunión retiro un retiro
obligatorio obligatorio
entonces a esa edad sacas tu dinero y
tienes que pagar tus impuestos lo que
pasa de este lado es que aquí no hay
ningún retiro obligatorio sale entonces
aquí no hay límite de edad no hay límite
d
bueno puede ser que te interesó que no
te interese bueno depende si quieres
retirarte antes o no o si quieres seguir
trabajando pero bueno entonces esto sea
nada más quería decirte esa última
información y toda la información de
este vídeo para que veas cómo son las
dos opciones y puedas pensar en cuál te
conviene más